what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch the second episode of what if i
believe this is the one with t'challa
chadwick boseman's last appearance as
black panther or actually no so just be
t'challa in this one right yeah
star
panther yeah i'm really much looking
forward to this we are of course prepped
your loki shirt my variant my
my tight-fitting black panther shirt
type because greg's put on a little bit
of weight
muscle sorry i just got a bane body now
you can still be sexy with a bang bang
forever
what if guys if you enjoy our reaction
subscribe and click that notification
bell hit that like button uh full length
watch along where you sync with the time
coder over at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of shows over there as well
at the same tier to get option for
reaction highlights and watch along
included lastly thank you for than doll
for editing down these highlights for us
let's watch what if episode two
[Music]
what if why if
i think it should be such a good one
yeah i can feel it
[Music]
drop it drop it now
identify yourself who me i am just an
ordinary junker
[Music]
i was waiting for the who
surely something this powerful that's
better off in my hands it's just that my
boss run
oh i should have not used the gun go
ahead really
ready oh yeah yeah yeah right here hit
me yeah oh my lord i didn't mean
do it again but this time faster harder
really
i barely moved hit me
these guys on the other hand
[Music]
what if star-lord was a real badass
a ravager never flies solo
[Laughter]
nice nice one i said a ravager never
flies
solo
yeah yondu
police tell me it's actually michael
rook who's the sleeping beauty
the beginning of his journey was much
more down to earth i am tired of living
in a bubble there's an entire world out
there bubba oh interesting though the
blood of a king runs through your veins
it is pumped by the heart of an explorer
a ravager spacecraft was arriving on
earth to abduct the spawn of the
celestial ego
[Laughter]
but in this universe
yondu outsourced the assignment to his
subordinates
oh
interesting really look like peter
quilty y'all sure i don't know all
humans look alike to me
what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring the world we can show
you all of them you're my new son forget
about ego
i don't miss with conor at all
i said yes
i haven't even been back
i had to pick a favorite really i could
not say i know i knows
how exactly did you stop thanos the mad
titan from decimating half of the
universe what i'm a big enough man to
admit when i'm wrong
here showed me there was more than one
way to reallocate the universe's
resource
i'm still asserting my plan was not
without its merits
[Music]
sounds like it's like how it should have
ended yeah
everybody is no good here hi please no
seriously we only take cash wait you are
the star-lord
[Laughter]
is that
it's not it's not his voice there's a
whole thing about it
we should take another one you look
terrible i'm sure it's fine no there's a
truly awful picture of him i don't know
he looks pretty good from where i'm at
wow
you ever think of going back yondu
attempted to return me to wakanda but it
had been destroyed
what they're called the embers of
genesis
with one ounce you can heal a dying
planet in minutes so who's the mark
tanaleer tavana
also known as the collector
so long as the collector's involved we
are not
john do
we steal from the rich and give to the
poor just like that earthling folk hero
of yours right robin leech robin
[Music]
[Laughter]
a museum that doubles as its base of
operations the mining colony
nowhere nowhere yondu and i will pose as
sellers looking to unload that orb you
recovered on morag but really it'll be
t'challa inside our head of security
proxima midnight wow
that is when you caused the distraction
hey
stop i thought we were faking it yeah
well try calling me captain genocide
again new guy
captain murder
we have a situation all units report to
our position
now yondu and nebula are free to
distract the collector so that i can
search for the embers
wow amazing
no notes a perfect plan no no no no
oh my dearest nebula aren't you aside
for a sword
i forgive me i couldn't help myself
that benusou
i don't
think it
sounds a little too
clear my guess he's compensating
quite articulate for a duck that sir is
very close-minded
[Music]
you know i can find him a cosmic flora
down the hall take a louie at the frost
giants the hard ralph with the cronin
that total snooze screw it
quack
[Music]
give me the tour
[Music]
the ravagers
it's a diversion sound the alarms lock
down the building
she's more of a character here than she
was in the movie absolutely
well they got the same actress for this
at least
oh damn
why does he have it oh the collector
destroyed wakanda maybe yeah
i mean he dropped that fact about it
being on a big old vibranium rock
my son
crown prince of wakanda was abducted
from earth by an alien spacecraft oh no
they were looking for him
oh cha-cha i had a debt with a collector
and you were the payment
nebs
i was protecting you are we talking
about the mission or is this family
stuff told me my homeland had been
destroyed my family killed how is that
protecting me whoa guess it's family
stuff
you don't belong down there with them
you belong up here with us with your
family you are not my family you never
were
i come from history has never looked
kindly on those who lock me in cages
it appears he does have a superpower
after all he can bore someone to death
using only his sanctimony
dissect him and strip his remains for
parts
let's go squidward
you are the worst
ah
naps but then again there are two sides
[Laughter]
this was always the plan
i told t'challa that the collector was
after him right from the jump you see i
have this debt with the collector and
well he's come to collect and what does
he want in a word you cha-cha cha-cha
hey it was t'challa's idea to keep you
in the dark cause he knew i would never
let him walk into a trap look where we
ended up
necessary cover to obtain this oh snap
job well done what about t'challa not to
worry he's keeping his escape plan
close to his chest not like that kareena
even though you are foolish
thank you i am forever in your date
i'm looking for howard
[Music]
now there's plenty more we can play with
oh my god
and mjolnir
what perhaps you prefer something much
more elegant
oh
that woman
he has guardian goddess of death
[Music]
are you crazy you'll never take them
yourself not crazy
that is weird to have that be a badass
mom
but i'm here for it
oh
yes
your new family has abandoned you karma
maybe you haven't yet
never fly solo
ain't no way in hell i was gonna leave
here without my
[Music]
kid damn he messed up oh
proxima good night
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
he's gonna become a life-sustaining
planet
oh that father and daughter duo
[Music]
any ideas sticky fingers could work
who's the clue you are because you lied
to me fair point it's like i thought
ragnarok sings let's do get help
that all you got
[Music]
how do you like it
i trust you'll know what to do with this
i have some ideas oh damn
no touching karina
no
no no no
stop and think i took care of all of you
i don't put a roof over your head oh
karma
[Laughter]
we're never getting out of here on foot
and we'll take to the skies
[Music]
nice and i will see you at the
rendezvous point copy that cha-cha
hey here gospel
i just wanted to say uh there's no need
i was the one who told you i wanted to
see the world all you did was show me
the universe
i've always felt at home up here but now
knowing everything i'm not quite sure
where i belong
on any planet among any people there
ain't no place in this galaxy where you
don't belong
ah
where you wanna be you're just gonna
have to follow your heart on that one mr
star-lord
of how he sits in a meditative position
yeah
truly the essence
interesting seeing thanos here yeah
under very different circumstances my
friend that sounds an awful lot like
genocide no no no because it's random
[Laughter]
how exactly my son came to be in your
spaceship funny story your highness you
see i took this job i was lost baba
yandu found me
and from one family reunion to another
uh sorry we're close my peter can't
spare a little time for dear old dad
what
but that's a story for another day oh
god oh geez so
oh dave you really should have picked up
peter quill
rest in peace absolutely
i am so glad that was a great episode
oh that was so oh man that was
i mean i like talking about
in the review of the last one i said it
like
while we were criticizing the last one
it's like but i have a feeling that
that's just the case because it's an
introduction episode that they would
really do something very different for
the follow-up yeah absolutely yeah this
is exactly what i wanted for what if
this episode was exactly what i wanted
this to be
solid
absolutely freaking
solid a and like if chadwick beau has
been killed it is like getting a
completely different side of t'challa
yeah it's like quintessentially his
voice but yeah like uh you get to see
him take on this whole other energy
that's all their personality i loved it
and i love the attention to detail of
like because
they picked him up instead the family
dynamic the group dynamic is a bit
different
very different yeah yeah yeah all right
yeah that was uh everything i wanted the
what-if concept to be
of pretty much taking a character
and putting them down just a different
path and then watching how it unfolds
and not doing like a remake of something
i thought that was a proper introduction
for the what-if concept for people to
really latch on to and understand it
with captain carter
but this is exactly what i wanted it
more to go now it's like this one little
not one little thing but a big thing of
choosing to take this kid instead of
peter quill
and then watching how that affects
everything completely different makes
everything unfold differently like the
ravagers or robin hoods now you know um
steal from the rich give to the poor
and then even watching like hey he
defeated thanos and managed to change
his mind and drax gets to
live a good life right now you know
his wife
brag about this yeah it was a big ordeal
i don't know the the ins and outs of it
so i don't know how dramatic it really
was but dave bautista was not
um
according to i think what happened was
dave bautista thought he wasn't asked
the creator said that they did send out
something so there might have been a
miscommunication i don't really know but
that wasn't dave bautista uh but either
way i thought the drax scene was still
really funny
korath stole the show the second
course they had the switch
of like because that's that's such a
famous mcu moment i'm star-lord
it's such a such an iconic moment and
then right from there they switch they
completely change the dynamic and he
reveres him so much and it just idolizes
him
like this is gonna be it this is exactly
what i was hoping it would be
and yeah and then you gotta still keep
chadwick bozeman as t'challa here where
he is you know he's still got the
wakanda accent
and he still feels like t'challa that's
the cool part is he he still feels like
t'challa just a much more fun more loose
adventurous side to him not that
t'challa is like unrelatable but he is
this like
royalty
yeah this is a much more loose version
more relatable and i love how he still
has the positive influence
over everything that's taking place and
he still wants to do good that it's not
just like hey the star-lord journey and
it even makes for a truly great
father-son dynamic between yondu and him
and i love that because yondu and peter
quill are always at odds yeah up until
like the final moments of guardians 2
and then here
they're like best buds
he looks after him and he's learned
clearly a lot from his instincts and
whatnot and yeah it's i loved that that
they
managed to split the difference and give
you both especially for t'challa because
you know i mean like this is a more
accessible for like all audiences kind
of show and i feel like yeah they for
him you know that was one of the gripes
about black panthers like oh you know he
does have to center everything with a
certain you know regal energy whereas
yeah here it's fun to have him be very
much in that character and within the
realms of that character but yeah loose
and having fun with it and across the
board i think that's one of the more fun
aspects to me about this is getting to
hear like jamon hansu seems like he put
everything into doing his voice
performance yeah this is a way more
exciting return than because he was
gonna be he's in captain marvel and i
remember being like oh cool jamon hansu
captain marvel yay that doesn't do
anything and he's barely in guardians
one jamal hansu isn't like him and david
desmarching are two actors who are like
in so many comic book properties yeah i
don't even realize just how many comic
book properties are in and then even
yeah but but jamon hans who's usually a
very serious type of actor
to get this side of him and like to me
to get this version of korath is so
great it is so like so funny he's at
times he was stealing the show for me
yeah absolutely like i i it's funny
because we were talking in the previous
episode about how you know partly with
the pace and also again the sort of uh
more encompassing shift in audience to
you know include kids more i feel like
in the first episode you could look it
in and go okay some of the humor seems
like it's really playing that direction
it's you know it's kind of obvious for
kids and here i thought they got much
richer character comedy out of stuff
like that where it's like the whole bit
with korath could have been annoying and
yet it just kept endearing me more and
more and more and and i even across the
other characters too like i loved the
recurring bit with thanos about you know
people were like you sound like a
genocidal guy yeah i don't know but
here's how you do it yeah
and hearing josh brolin even getting to
within the bounds of that character
still kind of get loose and have fun
with the dynamics and stuff
i think there is something about doing a
story that jumps off from a very
familiar place but then doesn't rely on
the plot points hardly at all that
really brings this episode especially
together because you can make all that
room to have these little offshoot
character moments some of which are just
like oh here's a joke to you know keep
the scene feeling light and then some of
which are actually no no here's just
what this character would be dealing
with in a different set of circumstances
but overall i i thought that every
moment was still essential even if it's
like a funny moment like with drax it
still shows the influence
that what what t'challa and the ravagers
have done how they're like actually
heroes here and on a personal level it's
kind of crazy how you know chadwick
boseman who passed away
um and now black panther the character
from all reports that we believe is not
i mean black panther the character is
not going to be in
like t'challa won't be in black panther
2 they're not doing recasting i mean i
know that's true i don't know if it's
going to be official that his character
is dead
but then uh you know yondu who's also
dead yeah like those these two
characters get a chance to have one last
rodeo together you know
characters who have passed on now
and for and it is so refreshing with
chadwick boseman just to get that i was
so pleased with it i was so
i was i i love this version of him i
really i really did love this version
and
it's crazy to see like man even in like
a voiceover work you're
you still have this like screen presence
it's so captivating strange yeah
and that's the thing is that's what's
wonderful too is yeah it it it's still
that regal quality is still there
because i think it's just part of
chadwick boseman yeah but yeah having
him be you know the more sort of uh you
know rogueish type is just so much fun
and it's weird because i think in part
you could sit here and go man i wish i
had seen this in live action but weirdly
it felt so alive here still you know and
i felt like i was still watching not
just listening to but really just
watching a real performance this felt
like top
tier like
oh i mean this in a good way guys
like a a solid disney animated movie
yeah you know yeah i don't mean that in
and uh
i feel like there's a really easy way to
make that sound insulting just because
you know disney the word of that but
disney makes some has made some of the
best animated movies of all time and and
to me this felt like a really great
disney animated movie yeah yeah yeah and
and well paced for for what it's trying
to do yeah there's only only a couple
nitpick moments of breath of things that
kind of happen so suddenly
but it's nowhere near the degree of what
we were feeling for the last episode
this got me more optimistic not that i
was pessimistic but i was like okay the
last episode you know had that hurdle of
cramming a two-hour plus movie
and beats and all into 30 minutes where
yeah this felt like it breathed better
there were still moments where i was
like we should breathe just a little
yeah literally i'm not saying like 20
minutes i'm saying like five minutes
yeah
yeah i think like a couple of more
minutes would have just helped a few
moments yeah but they're like tiny tiny
little details
but versus the other one and i don't
want to just do a comparison i'm just
saying i'm using this to say this is why
this what-if scenario works so well is
because
taking a completely different plot
allows you to tell a short story
versus feeling like you're doing a
condensed movie
and doing a short story here you get um
you get like actual tension in certain
moments like when he goes into the ship
and when it when um his necklace starts
lighting up and he you see it's a
wakanda ship and you know about the
collector like
to me that's like an oh [ __ ] moment
of oh damn what's happening i'm curious
i'm like pulled in to what the plot
development is going to be
and to the character journey of this
version of t'challa i'm
sincerely pulled in to the emotional
journey of this kid who wants to be an
explorer so you get this sense of wonder
and then having to return home and then
you get this complete dovetail here of
both of his families coming together in
the end
and it was great it was literally a
great episode because it told its own
story yeah and wasn't reliant other than
like you know pulling from other things
and having some fun with it like i
thought having like the black order in
here was was pretty cool some of them
got to have more personality and they
did an infinity war
and um
yeah because he had like corvus glaive
ebony ma proxima midnight and then who
what is that other freaking guys i
constantly black dwarf black dwarf is
there's another character giant who's
wasn't in the movie super giant yeah
it's not in the movie so we're trying to
commit that to memory here yeah and i'm
like did they appear in the background
somewhere here or whatever or in one of
the you know like different gallery
shots because the other thing is i'm
really
you know there are going to be so many
breakdowns of all the things in the
backgrounds and all of those collection
cases then this to me it was another
case of how i thought they
managed to utilize characters who
weren't aren't really used
and
elevate them uh maybe depending on the
scenario like the collector
it was cool to see like look at all
those collections look at the kingpin
version of the collector the real like
galaxy
like crime lord yeah that he is it seems
like a threat not just yes centric like
it was fun when you're watching him pull
you know the mallet kit dagger i think
there's a malcolm dagger right did he
say he said like an l agent elvin yeah
it might have been probably malikith and
then
uh uh hella obviously
uh so yeah then i'm like there's there's
plenty of easter eggs later in here that
totally flew over my head but it's gonna
be fun to watch a new rockstars video to
see everything that's pointed out here
but yeah like uh dealing with
dealing with the collector and getting a
chance to
have it feel more inhabited there's
something about like i like benicio del
toro as the collector and i like the
appearances that they've had but for
some reason i feel like this one might
stick with me longer as a more like
clear definitive version of
that like this is more defined yeah i
mean he's not even though he's an
important character he in this feels
less you know i mean because he gets to
take up so much more of the episode and
because it is very clearly he's the
villain yeah the conflict is directly at
least as of the operation between them
whereas yeah and guardians it's more of
you know an interlude of the movie
itself and i mean i think there's
something it's funny that it's not be
nicio del toro here because when he's on
screen i think part of it is like i'm
just kind of engrossed by like this dude
always comes up with like you know
eccentric interesting characters and and
here
and it's not even that i would gripe at
the live-action movies and say i'm
distracted by his presence but there's a
different experience in watching it
where here i was just like this is the
collector i'm not even really thinking
about that beyond the initial moments of
trying to identify his voice yeah yeah
yeah that's a fair thing getting nebula
and nebula and thanos having a little
moment there where
it's kind of like watching dwayne
johnson and emily blunt
one nebula too like i thought she was a
nice little central fresh character and
yeah in a in an interesting mood like in
a fun sort of like confident swagger
that's you know nice to see in contrast
from the movies where she's just so dark
and having uh that karina girl who she's
the one who grabs the power stone and
and guard into the galaxy and um
she's like
no longer to be the slave or some
dialogue like i'm not part of your
collection
but getting a chance
to do
uh to come back here pretty much go down
the same path
but coming out all right this time yeah
absolutely absolutely only to then give
us a
stinger that seems like it's gonna be
pretty sinister for this but yeah it's
kind of it's insane because it's such
like a great heartfelt episode
and you get this like really warm tender
ending here
where t'challa is truly not resentful
towards uh yondu in any capacity and and
doesn't even want to give a full
explanation to his dad he's just like uh
what he said something like he saved me
or something like that oh yeah yeah yeah
he found me he found me lost and he
found me exactly that's the one yeah
that doesn't have to sting over peter
quill he gotta live and on earth and
standards work with the dairy queen and
then his dad shuts down like oh great
over the end of the world oh should we
should we have picked him so we really
should have been
like what was the cost i think that's
the funny thing don't make fans wish
that it played out this way yeah
let them know why it's good it didn't
play off this so that's the thing though
is and that's part of the periphery
magic of this concept in general is like
yeah we got this swashbuckling adventure
that's very feel good but also the cost
of these little differences could be
this one big cataclysmic difference yeah
i love that yeah i really love that yeah
and um well and two i mean i even got
caught up in the whole thing about like
wakanda's been destroyed oh wait it's
not been destroyed and i feel like that
motivates that ending button of like i
mean what does t'challa have to be
really that pissed about when actually
he's got two families yeah you know
that's a very good point because you
know when they say o'connor's a struggle
like damn that's devastating and then
i've really felt for him in that moment
of
uh
because this whole one thing that was a
little bit odd to me was it did seem
like little boy this is why i mean like
a couple more minutes will it help some
of these beats breathe a little better
because he's you know like t'challa it
seemed like he could as a kid just
couldn't give a [ __ ] about leaving home
i'm like i feel like a kid would still
like kind of care maybe be a little
conflicted in the moment this is
immediate because it went by so quick
that moment yeah of like that's the
wrong kid
yeah you don't seem too weirded out how
would you like to see it all all right
let's go you know let's go for years and
years and never return like i i think
letting a moment linger a little more of
what do you want to do kid do you want
to come back do you want to come with us
you know like giving him the option just
letting a moment be there where he has
to make a choice
probably would have helped compliment
that moment in the ship better when he's
when he's there and he's like oh i made
this choice and my family has been
worried and looking for me this whole
time because i really did feel all that
what i just said like my family's been
working looking for me this whole time i
just think it would have been that much
more powerful or hit a lot harder if we
did have that at that moment breathe a
little longer we're little boy t'challa
and people might argue with me i could
already hear the comments people might
argue with me that you know uh t'challa
didn't have a choice that yonder was
going to take him but i don't think it
played that way it wasn't like a peter
quill kidnapping thing they obviously
got the wrong kid
and i feel like yondu was kind of
leaving it up in his hands the little
boy's hands i think he was just like
this little kid doesn't seem weirded out
maybe he wants to come but i think yandy
would have given him a choice well it
does make you wonder is this universe is
yondu just a pretty different guy or is
it just that t'challa rubbed off on him
after you know so much time a little bit
both yeah a little bit of both and i
think it is that it's like when he goes
out and he's you know you could tell
yeah he wants to explore he wants
adventure it's not such that you know
it's like he lead it's not the kind of
thing where he leaves his his his
father's chambers in some kind of
anguished way where it's like oh there's
been a wedge and i need to leave it's
yeah it's more just sort of like oh that
he happened to discover a way outside
and then oh [ __ ] i get picked up by the
ship so yeah it does feel a little bit
like okay i guess i'll just go with you
at first but what i appreciate it is
that i think we even wondered it out
loud during the reaction and then soon
after the episode came back to that fact
of like your home you know what it was
destroyed they addressed it really quick
yeah so at least you know
i i always appreciate i guess when i
have a gripe arise and then the show
takes care of it in the text yeah yeah
even moments later yeah essentially
doing it mm-hmm and it was also because
the uh one of them i think back to the
black order of
aren't they kind of aren't they known as
like the
the children of thanos or something like
that i think they're that's one of their
names
the children of thanos and then to watch
like
them
fight thanos the gardener
providing the galaxy with organic
produce so funny
oh that is
it's america
it is like a villain pub moment
it really yeah it really is
and i wa and i would not be at all
surprised if not that it is in any way
sort of overt but i wouldn't be
surprised if if they are putting some
you know covert love some latent love to
the villain pub in there because you
they have to have seen those yeah and i
like the visuals a lot i thought they
look great look absolutely beautiful
like getting just the cosmic side of it
all right i will say that if i you know
considering i gotta give at least one
one little
uh lead up to the
first episode is i thought the action is
different in the first episode more
appealing i thought the way they like
they did some unique camera things with
the action the first one and here i like
i loved everything here and i liked the
action i wasn't in love with it whereas
like the last episode i was like my main
takeaway was how cool the action is yeah
the last one put me in a place where i
felt like i was watching an actual
choreographed live fight scene yeah and
yet still you know it's like there's
something about animation where you're
like well they can do anything yeah you
know so
yeah this one i think too it's setting
it in a more futuristic realm setting it
in space i think there's something about
that too that just kind of acclimates
you in a different way to action like
that where you know yeah it's gonna be
more fantastical and that kind of uh
changes the amount of like visceral
punch it has yeah some of it had a
little bit more like the
the brutal
aspects to it and not as like hyper
choreographed and martial arts heavy
yeah yeah other than some like t'challa
maneuvers but um you know like watching
uh thanos and go up against the black
order or even like when they're fighting
the collector like that that was a cool
moment when yondu and t'challa are
fighting him side by side have a little
thor ragnarok moment yeah
um and then howard the duck too that was
good for the moment
yeah hey he can even that but even that
like because that's a joke and it's a
callback too
uh but also you know they made something
out of that even though howard is mostly
a joke character it's like that little
passage gets us to the next part of the
story it's not just a detour to make a
reference yeah
and i'm sure we'll see howard again
they made i thought they made full use
of uh this this
this is good this is great
this is awesome this made me super happy
i i was pretty much smiling from
beginning to end i
had to stop smiling at one point because
my cheeks started hurting yeah yeah well
and even more so than the previous
episode like that just the artwork
the way it looks like you know comic
book splash pages or even sci-fi concept
art like
even more in this episode i was feeling
those vibes you know well it's it is
interesting because it's a similar type
of animation to the first episode
obviously yet
uh because of the color palette and the
settings it doesn't feel exactly the
same and they made it like i think they
do make like between this one and and
the first one i feel like they do make
some like you know period appropriate
for uh the peggy carter episode like
camera and lensing choices
via the animation and so yeah here i
feel like they're capturing it in a more
futuristic cinematography scale you know
well they also really know how to honor
the world from the main movies they're
riffing off of yeah too i thought they
do a great job at that
um yeah i thought this was
this is refreshingly awesome
this is refreshingly awesome i'm i'm
really happy that you know it's always a
it might not be live action but it is
cool to get a voiceover performance from
the late chadwick bozeman in a way that
lets you still feel how alive he is even
if it's through voice work like you can
feel him in the booth really interact
you can like get that sense yet i'm not
getting pulled out thinking of the actor
in the booth yeah yeah like it really
feel and and i think that's part of the
overall magic of having so not everybody
but so many of the cast return for these
is they do kind of transcend feeling in
certain ways or at least this episode
especially did transcends feeling like
just a like a fun tacked on thing and
feels like an actual journey that we're
you know lucky to see with all these
people assembly yeah i think sometimes
the profile shots of when characters are
talking
the the animation on the mouth
is not very good on profile shots
or it's suddenly it's just like they're
having a mouth kind of move up and down
but it's not really matching yeah
like that's hard it is hard and if and
yeah in this show i was noticing too i
was like when they're facing like yondu
especially
yeah if they're looking more toward the
camera it's actually pretty alright but
yeah some of those profiles could could
be a bit better
but overall
uh amazing i'll give it like an i'll
give it like a eight point five out of
ten give it a ten and a half out of five
i i have one easter egg question to
verify that's because i want it on the
record what's up in guardians of the
galaxy his eyes are blue right
who's uh star-lord when he first opens
the eyes on his helmet are blue right
i feel like they are because they're not
they're not they're purple because at
the beginning of the episode i think
you're wrong about that oh they i could
be
they're our lord helmet guardians of the
galaxy yeah
yeah i'm remembering this red are they
red okay but they're not they're not
purple though no okay good as long as
that because even if yeah right
t'challa's eyes are purple yeah and like
i love that too it's like the carrying
some of that wakanda you know heritage
yeah just a little detail like that so
when somebody points out that easter egg
i noticed it
awesome good to hear all right guys what
did you think about this episode did you
enjoy it as much as us skirt i'll say 9
out of 10.
9.9 out of 10.
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
um also
uh we're on patreon and uh
mikhail linden
mikhail
i wanted to shout you out because
chadwick bozeman
final performance in mcu
did wonders
for being the first black marvel
or mcu superhero
respectful and you are the whitest guy
at our patreon page i just thought it
would be totally humorous
if the whitest guy i know oh shout out
the whitest guy in her patreon
for the chadwick coachman episode
mikhail what's up my white friend
us white people gotta stick together in
2021 my friend we gotta keep our
heritage alive and appreciated by all
the people around we gotta make sure
that it's in the forefront of everyone's
mind michael and i appreciate you that
you and i can do that just by showing up
in a room and having a face and having
the lights be on so uh hey man keep on
your whiteness uh you're doing a great
job listen you're a great wife you live
in in europe and so like that's the
birthplace of all white people you know
that
dude what if you weren't born there you
might be a totally different race a
person mikhail don't let that happen i
don't want to know what that reality is
like
i can't handle things outside of my
white
[Laughter]
stay fragile
[Music]